let's see where we I would like to start
with this
Dr
okay uh and so we're just going to move
him he's
pushing so you have to ground that and
then you have to project and you can't
if you're not grounding when you push
him he'll push you back he's got the
base he's got the
iner you have to push him and um I would
like uh Ronin and Taylor to not take
those for the FL and eight you're more
here and you're going to do the same
thing so here you're as you're moving
into me I release the tension like the
bottom of the uh of the pet you see so
the sword goes up and then I release and
that's what lowers me so you're young
you got I want you to go slow again okay
so you can feel maybe you have to be a
little lighter so you can feel what's
happening okay so I start to
release and you feel that and I get
heavier on the on the ground okay it
doesn't have to do with my hands it
doesn't have to do with my hands I just
release and you'll compress into me you
see okay but my hands haven't moved and
then I project that back
out you could do the 10 to two we can do
the
[Music]
12 you really I'm really standing
myself the tension
okay let's these things
you get push back a little when you push
on can you
seeing look at his spine I don't
know get out of
uh you're
like get it it'll do it cuz you
understand you're like really hard there
okay sof
wow see
that when you
grab when you start to push
Tes same no
desire say
no
[Music]
no when you relax you
relax like it should not
be but it feels like you're here and
then you're going to you're going to be
loose get it
then you
loosen the the quaw and the lower T it
feels like that
that can you see what I what's happening
is I go here you're going to be loose
and then yes comes back so this stays
still this part does not take tension
okay
well my
arms all
right a little different okay so he's
coming in I'm going to project and I'll
stick on the on the projection energy I
don't and I don't know where you're
going to get it okay so you're going to
project and then you're going to stick
on the on the other side so you're
working both your there's your C you
right you're going to co and then going
to stick on that side so there's going
to be a lot of young energy right as you
you send them back and that's the one
you you use to get okay
okay try
it all right I want to feel it
kind this so when I when I I go you see
watch watch what happen so in in your
grip I'm already going to start adhering
so in the
grip projecting off and then trying to
catch it projecting off and then you're
trying to catch it this
how in the in the grip I'm already there
and then I come over that's one way
other way
is but it's the same see I'm here and
I'll project but I'm already in
here you can't
go not going to work you're adhering in
the grip
[Music]
on the
arm do that side
again are we going to project but I'm in
hearing you can open your GD project
with the
ad I'm not going
is the adhesion and then I can change
the
direction here even though your thumbs
are close it's in the
adhesion you
see it said hearing already be with me
project
there that's it
okay there yeah you got the same
thing
here there you go now keep that feeling
yep keep it yes keep
good there you see how it's sticky you
can go either way you can you can go
backwards you or forward see so go just
a little go a little
forward bring bring me bring me e there
you go bring me a little
bo come
on okay here we
yeah so I go so as I
go so feel the feel the pressure so one
yours
come one
increasing more it's not not that I'm
it's not that I'm pushing down but it
gets increase that would that would be
slippery you see and you're going to get
more that okay
so fres
friction yeah yes that's
it okay yeah you're
you're you have the dichotomus on off C
your I key it's just one thing okay all
right play with it
okay now now we're going to move away
from the drill but everything's the same
okay so he's coming in right he's got
his young
aspect and I'm going to step to the side
and
project you're going have to find your
ground pop on
[Music]
movement it's even if my dance is deep
it's not off my back foot it's on my
back foot on my back
foot on my
back okay I want you to clear the line
of attack get to one of the 45s and do
the projection which we were doing
already okay right
I want you to use the more
angles so the
10 I think you can relax a little more
still a little
tight you still
have just
relax
rela Rel
that tiny little tiny
little tiny
little this part is this part is
I know you can get away with
it we hit the
ground what we
want without the arm tension
running and now we'll do this same
thing
and
okay in these drills you can move your
you're going to do it
here
here and every time you move your feet
the foot that is not moving has to find
the
ground then
remember you know I'm talking so as as
you go you're going to project right and
you think you're going to uh you're like
you go away so you're going to go here
but if you're just walking normal
instead of grounding it's not going to
be there okay or or it fluctuates so
he's going away and you like you're
trying to catch up with
it you have to going away I have to
eventually stop one foot at least
okay
um do do the
other you got to Pro with all right
project with I already start S there's a
break there project with I project with
it yeah there you there you
go project with I
no yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes okay we got to get to the next step
okay so you project like not back and
foror hi
[Music]
okay so if we if we take yesterday's
drill
you
see the the e
i i i can do it the same exact way
everything that we just did is the same
way okay
so
when I'm here I'm not just getting out
of the
way same thing open your grip same thing
you see feel how you feel my skin
my skin moov you see that
okay that's that's what I'm in doing
inside your bre so it can move you you
see and it also brings you
in got it so I just in here and I'm
doing it here you
see
okay open right I have to find that I
have to find the adhesion the adhesion
is moving you see and I have to keep it
okay and we'll leave you a counter off
for now okay so I I'm in here the same
thing you see same thing coming this way
now oh
this and then I find the ground p i aim
your Center and I find the ground P even
though moving it's
moving it's not
this his body body
and let's
try right so I'm feeling for
that poke you with the IC okay got it
you don't have to kill me
but oh go off so as soon as as you did
have the the external like there was
inertia there do you see and then you
cut against it show you what I mean okay
so I'm bring I bring you this way and
then I can cut against see okay but I I
am going to for example if you pulling
you're pulling you see I'm bringing you
you see and it stays
on you see
that go just go slow to to keep it start
it here start it here start it here keep
it there yep it's still there
okay and then when you move you move
that adhesion not my not my hand move
the adhesion move it move it move it
move it move it move it yes yes yes yes
yes same thing if you were going to
project me feel the same in the let's
move
yes then take it take it okay but let's
round that a
little oh round it yes
yes H thank you